ce travail est incroyable bien c'est ma
partie préférée de prendre des photos vous vous
promenez et trouvez des endroits comme celui-ci
qui me fait un peu délirer un peu comme
ce que vos yeux me font en ce
moment c'était vraiment ringard non c'était euh un
peu ringard euh peut-être que je  Je te reverrai ici un jour
tu as dit qu'il était mignon les
emojis sont mignons ce mec fait fondre mes
lunettes de soleil tess
je pense que tu pourrais vendre ce truc mais
il manque quelque chose
comme toutes tes photos tu
je t'aime tusa
[Musique]
bienvenue  de retour dans le monde des vivants
peut-être que tu n'aimes pas trop
parler de toi pourrais-tu s'il te plait me dire
que tu pensais à quelqu'un d'
autre j'aimerais juste pouvoir le revoir une
fois de plus même pour une minute
il l'aimait et il savait  que
[Musique]
je ne comprends pas ce qui se passe
quand la séparation est dramatique il y a
des affaires inachevées il est
entre les deux
il vous tend la
main votre assistant de chasse aux fantômes
est arrivé une planche ouija
oh mon dieu j'ai déménagé désolé c'était
moi si tu réussis à traverser il n'y
aura peut être pas de retour
je le retrouverai
[Musique]
je suis toujours là cette
toi